[MUSIC PLAYING]
NAZMUL IDRIS: I'm Nazmul Idris.
I'm a developer advocate on
the Android team at Google.
This is "UXD for
Developers," the show
where you can learn how to
create better user experiences.
Today we're going to talk
about what UX actually means.
With me I have a special
guest, Izabel Idris,
who is a mobile
interaction designer that
works for [? Good ?] Technology.
Thanks for joining us.
IZABEL IDRIS: Thanks.
NAZMUL IDRIS: So, Izabel.
I hear the words UX design
get thrown around a lot,
and especially in many
different contexts.
People say, if you do
is, you have a good UX.
If you do that,
you're going to have
a bad experience and your
users will have a bad time.
So what is UX?
IZABEL IDRIS: Well
User Experience Design
is really an emergent
property of design
that includes visual
design, interaction
design, and engineering.
So you can see the slide
how all of these things
really need to come together,
and the whole must be greater
than the sum of its parts.
So if any one of these
things aren't great,
they're going to let down
the overall user experience.
So user experience
really involves
you focusing on all
the details, as well as
being able to really
zoom out and make sure
that what you're delivering has
an overall really great user
experience.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That makes sense.
So you mentioned the
words "visual design"
and "interaction design."
Can you describe the
differences between the two.
IZABEL IDRIS: So I'm an
interaction designer,
so I'll start with
interaction design.
It really involves designing
a sequence of screens,
are sequence of
steps, that the user
has to go through in
your application, which
is what we call "flow,"
in order for your user
to accomplish certain tasks.
So those tasks
depend on whatever
it is that your
application actually does.
So interaction design
takes into account
how a user interacts with
the data and the UI elements
on each one of your
screens, as well as
how they interact with all
of the screens together.
So the data and
the UI really has
to be strong together in a way
that makes sense for the user.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That makes sense.
IZABEL IDRIS: So if
you look at the slide,
this is an example of a flow
that an interaction designer
might give to a developer.
So the next slide here
is annotated wire frame.
So this is something else that I
would also give to a developer.
So the different
annotations show
what each one of those
UI elements mean.
So right here we're
showing the action bar.
So we have the app icon,
a spinner, some icons,
and an overflow.
So a visual designer,
what they do
is they really specify the
color palette, the iconography,
the typography, and all
the visual personality
of your application.
So they would specify
the exact spacing
for all the layouts of
every single screen.
So if you look at
the slide here,
this is what we would
call a "red line."
So you can see it's a
very detailed layout
of that particular screen.
So visual designers would
provide the engineers
all the graphics,
assets, and the icons,
and make sure that each
screen is just perfect.
So there's one other
example of a visual design.
These are some things that a
visual designer would actually
deliver to an engineer.
These are like the
different sizes
for your icons, all the
different font sizes, and icon
set for your entire application.
NAZMUL IDRIS: So
essentially you're
skinning the application.
You're creating that
wonderful experience--
I mean the visual aspect
of that experience that
is going to immediately
be striking to someone.
IZABEL IDRIS: Yeah.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That makes sense.
IZABEL IDRIS: So
interaction design,
you can kind of think of
it that they would provide
more of a low-res wire frame,
and then a visual design
would give you a high-res
mock that's really detailed.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That makes sense.
So I get it.
So basically UX design has to
take into account interaction
design, on visual
design, and engineering,
and put them all
together in the way that
delivers the light
at the end of day.
Right?
IZABEL IDRIS: Yep.
NAZMUL IDRIS: So from a
developer's perspective,
the way I'd like to think about
it is that I write code that
might-- there's a
visual code I write,
the non-visual code I write.
And both of those come together
to deliver the overall user
experience, but the visual code
specifically delivers the UI.
Is that a good way to
think about it as well.
IZABEL IDRIS: Yeah.
And I think that Google Now
is a really great example
of a product that delivers a
really great user experience.
And it really embodies
awesomeness at every level--
the interaction, the
visual, and the engineering.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Right.
IZABEL IDRIS: So I
think it's something
that we can talk about
a little bit more.
Do you have any examples of how
an application or experience
like Google Now
could hypothetically
have gone terribly wrong?
NAZMUL IDRIS: Definitely.
So we were talking about
visual design for quite a bit.
So Google Now, one of the
most striking things about it
is that the cards are
really, really easy to read.
The typography is great.
It's very easy to digest
a lot of information
without thinking much at all.
So if Google Now delivered the
same quality of information,
it was accurate and relevant,
but if it looked really bad,
like if the margins are
off and the padding was off
and the images are
all ugly, then I
think it would
make the user think
that it was a very
unprofessional application.
IZABEL IDRIS: Yeah.
I think that things like
typography and spacing
and that polish
that's in Google Now
is one of the things that
makes it so successful.
Of course, the relevant data
surfacing just when you needed
is crucially important.
But what I really
love about Google Now
is how I can just glance
at a card in just a second,
I can get a lot of
information from it.
If there's really low
cognitive load to those cards,
I can just glance
at it and that's it.
NAZMUL IDRIS:That makes sense.
So visual design
is very important.
IZABEL IDRIS: Yep.
NAZMUL IDRIS: So kind of
switching gears a little bit.
So let's say the
visuals for Google
Now-- since we are
talking hypothetically
about how the UX
could go hardly wrong.
So let's say Google Now had
just amazing data was surfacing,
the content was
totally-- I'm sorry.
If the cards looked
really great,
as they do today, but let's
say the data was lacking,
like it didn't know
your current location,
or it surfaced a card
about some upcoming flight
that you have to be on
and the details wrong.
So in that situation, that would
be really bad user experience.
Right.
IZABEL IDRIS: Yes.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Because one thing
that I would feel at that point
as a user is that I can't
trust the information that I'm
getting, even though it
looks visually striking.
IZABEL IDRIS:Yeah.
Trust is a really important
part of user experience.
I'm glad you brought that up.
Because trust is one of
those emergent properties
that has to do with really
great design and really
great engineering.
So I think trust is something
that as developers we
should all really focus on.
Because when someone
trusts your application,
that's what's going to
get your users to give you
these five-star reviews
in the app store.
And these reviews
are what's going
to make you
ultimately successful.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That's true.
And then you get to
share your application
as well, and then the
social proof in what you're
doing and so on,
IZABEL IDRIS: Exactly.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Absolutely.
Trust is one of those very, very
important emergent properties
I think that everybody
should aspire to accomplish.
So let's use a different
example than Google Now.
So I think we've highlighted how
bad visual design could wreck
a user experience, how bad
engineering could wreck it.
So let's talk about how bad
interaction design could also
wreck it.
So we've all used
Android phones.
And if you think back at
the first minute experience
you had with a
new Android phone,
the first thing
Android asks you to do
is sign into your Gmail account.
Once you've done
that, it basically
automatically signs you into
all the other Google apps
that you have, like
Play, Maps, and YouTube.
So imagine an alternate
universe where,
instead of this wonderful
flow, we add a lot of friction.
Where, let's say, you've
initially signed in with Gmail,
but then for every other Google
application that you go to run,
you now have to sign into it
over and over and over again.
What would the user
think in that situation?
I would be almost discouraged
from using my phone in the ways
that I want to use it because
of the tremendous amount
of friction that had been
created in the interaction
that I'm having with these
different applications.
So it's a higher-level
flow, if you will,
of how a user interacts
with your phone that's
being impacted by
individual decisions that
are being made at the
application level.
IZABEL IDRIS: Yeah.
That's one of those aspects of
being able to get the details
right and then actually
zooming out and looking
at how all those details, and in
this case, how the first minute
experience of using all
these applications really
affects the overall
user experience, which
is the Android user
experience of the phone.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Exactly.
Exactly.
So it's almost as
if you'd have to be
a good citizen as an
application developer.
Your applications have to be
a good citizen on the device,
and not only deliver
a good experience
inside of that
application, but also
in the context of the larger
phone or operating system
that it's actually living in.
IZABEL IDRIS: Exactly.
NAZMUL IDRIS: It also impacts
things like battery life
and so on.
OK.
So it's clear that many
things need to come together
to make a user
experience truly great.
And clearly that design is
everyone's responsibility.
IZABEL IDRIS: Exactly.
Designers alone cannot create
great user experiences.
So I want to say that one time,
that designers alone cannot
create a great user experience,
and are not responsible alone
for creating a user experience.
It takes an entire team.
So great user experience
really involves equal amounts
of amazing design and
amazing engineering effort,
and really amazing
is across the board
by all the members
of the product team.
So just to give a shout out
to all these other people that
are not engineers or designers.
These include tech
writers, product managers,
project managers, and
directors, managers.
So you really need
excellence at every level.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Definitely.
And also I think we
should also shout out
to user researchers,
prototypers and so who are also
part of the design
team that contribute
in a big way to making sure
the experience actually works.
IZABEL IDRIS: Exactly.
NAZMUL IDRIS: I mean,
works for users.
IZABEL IDRIS: Yeah.
And designers can work
to create and prototype
really amazing designs.
But in the end of the
day, these designs
still have to get
built by engineers.
So an example,
let's say a designer
creates a really amazing
and elegant and functional
mobile news reader application.
And they test it with users.
It has really great
user feedback.
And they say, OK.
This design is perfect.
So they give it
to the engineers.
But when the engineers
build it, they
don't put in
prefetching, caching,
and they don't do
efficient data transfers,
and they drain the battery.
NAZMUL IDRIS:
[INAUDIBLE] tells us
we should always do
efficient data transfers.
IZABEL IDRIS: Always do
So these amazing
designs are never
going to be fully
realized or appreciated
due to these bad
engineering practices.
And this is something that
designers have no control over.
They can't control if you
use prefetching, caching,
and if you do data
transfers inefficiently.
So overall this is going
to result in a bad user
experience.
You're usually going to feel
impatient and frustrated
and overall have a bad time.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Definitely.
IZABEL IDRIS: So UX design
is really important.
It's everyone's responsibility.
And it's really important
that everyone in the team
comes together to make
a great experience.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Awesome.
Well thank you so much
for joining us today.
This has been a great show.
Do you want to plug
the UX Community?
Oh yeah.
Free to join our Google+
design community.
The link will be in
the description below.
And we're going to put a
link to the episode on here.
And if you have any questions
or comments about our episodes,
or just any questions
about UX in general,
or if you have
suggestions about topics
you want us to cover
for upcoming shows,
please feel free to
leave us a post on there.
And we also curate a tremendous
amount of really good user
experience-related information,
especially for developers.
So please check that out
for that reason as well.
I think you again,
and see you next time.